Guten Morgen Linus Was muss man eigentlich machen um im Parlament gesperrt zu werden.
Das weiß ich auch nicht so genau aber ich werde es herausfinden.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Ausgabe mit der Nummer 257 aufgezeichnet am 7 juli 1900.
2000.
Von dem her von Themenheft fühlte ich mich wieder irgendwie wie 1900 2018 im Studio,
in ihren Studio sind Linus und Thomas Timm,
lässt sich entschuldigen und wir haben uns gedacht haben inzwischen einen derartigen Themen Stau dass Thomas und ich uns nach der doch etwas längeren lnp 256 Pause nun schon mal wieder.
Mit den wichtigsten Themen bei euch melden.
Ja ich habe Flair leider nur wenn Boots teilnehmen können also ich habe nach gehört und.
Gehört oder Video geguckt.
Gehört ja ich bin ein alter Bekannter hatte sich auch noch das Video anzuschauen.
Ja also.
Ja ich bin so ein bisschen verwundert oder wie soll ich das sagen ich habe auch mal geschaut bei der mp200 die Videoaufrufe sind auch relativ wenig also,
im Vergleich zu zu den Audio aufrufen also irgendwie keine Ahnung wenige 1000 Videoaufrufe na während die Download der Audiodatei natürlich dann bisschen höher sind.
Ich denke schon dass ich das Video lohnt ich bin jetzt also,
aber ich habe natürlich auch den Blick darauf dass wir diesen ganzen Aufwand betrieben haben um ein Video zu haben ne und,
und Menschen dazu haben wir auf der Bühne etwas zu machen und so ich bin natürlich der Ansicht dass ich das lohnt das,
das Video zu schauen ich weiß aber natürlich zimmerschau nicht ob sich das lohnt das Video zu schon wenn man das Auto schon gehört hat ich glaube da muss ich mal mit ihm müssen uns mal überlegen das Schießen uns immer so bisschen selber Infos na das irgendwie so dadurch dass wir die Episoden ja perroud als Audio veröffentlichen die meisten Leute einfach ganz normal das da hören und dann sagen na ja jetzt wollen wir nicht noch mal insert Video anzuschauen.
Hörverstehen.
Ja Video fährst vielleicht da war zumindest doch im Audio der viele lache gehört die sich daneben teilweise auf dieser Didi Video Show genau die live Zeichen bezogen haben also das ist vielleicht ein guter Grund aber wie.
Das war diesmal auch so es war großartig will nur ganz kurz zu dir Zettel Auszeichnungen habe nämlich extra es gibt ja mehrere Versionen,
auf auf YouTube dann also die wieder et impera es gibt auch eine Version buskase wo wo du quasi das Screen recording hast von Roland,
der da eben wie gesagt zu gezeichnet hat dann siehst Du gar nicht die ganzen radiogesicht der da auf der Bühne so also Tim und mein radiogesicht und unsere hübschen Gäste,
sondern du siehst halt diese diese live Zeichnungen für zu Hause kann man das kann man glaube ich so auf wenn man jetzt irgendwie sagt zu euch bin eh so.
Ich höre nur hin dann kann man sich halt wieder schöne live zeigen und dazu laufen lassen die immer das größte Feedback und den großen Applaus bekommt bei unseren Live-Sendung insofern das glaube ich ist das was ich was ich dann tatsächlich lohnt wer also den anderen Kram damit Video anzuschauen,
muss wahrscheinlich gar nicht unbedingt sein sind halt Menschen auf einer Bühne aber Diesel Eiszeit das leicht zeichnungs Video lohnt sich glaube ich schon sehr ist verlinkt in den Shorts außerdem lohnt sich natürlich das Vorprogramm das Vorprogramm war sehr spaßig,
bambergerplatz das jeopardy was Henning und letti da gemacht haben.
Mit der Technik von von Dennis und da gibt's 44,
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten die da gegeneinander angetreten sind und das sollte man sie auf jeden Fall als Video anschauen weil das auch so mit mit Bilder Rätseln und sowas ist das war auch ein sehr großer Spaß,
von der Sendung selber alle alle Erinnerungen die ich da woran habe habe ich sie mir auch noch mal angehört habe weil das halt schon natürlich irgendwie eine.
Bei aller Vorbereitungen und aller vielleicht auch Routine die wir da inzwischen haben sollten eben sehr auf sehr stressig ist sowas,
zu machen so ein Event ne und die Leute da und hier was und da klemmt was und so das war deswegen habe ich gar nicht so viel Erinnerung daran,
aber was ich an Feedback höre war es eine war sehr schön und sehr lustig und Leute waren.
Man glaube ich sehr zufrieden und ich eigentlich dann nachher auch.
Ja es hat schon fast wieder so den den Charakter einer Gala also ihr tut euch der wirklich enormen Aufwand an und das hat sich aber raus,
also das ist das ist glaube ich auch ganz wichtig für die Community mit uns wirklich leid dass ich nicht dabei sein konnte ich war nicht Dahlien an dem Tag aber ja,
bins wieder mal in deinem dezimal oder bitte Sprung gibt es sollte man das sicherlich wiederholen.
Wir werden ja wahrscheinlich bei der privacy week,
kann ich häufig schon mal vorsichtig ankündigen unter Umständen könnte es sein dass wir und dass unsere Einreichung zur privacy week angenommen wird und dann hätten wir eine,
wird spätestens die nächste Live-Sendung zur privacy week dann auch mit dir in Wien.
Suche das freut mich natürlich sehr privacy Weg ist irgendwann im Oktober und in Wien wer in Österreich ist oder sich hier im Raum für Netzpolitik interessiert heute aufjedenfall hinschauen.
Ansonsten die hat ihm die LMP 256 hat er dann noch eine nach Party am nächsten Tag.
Und zwar unter dem Titel AFD wegbassen War II der große die Großdemonstration der AFD wo die,
wo die AFD dann auch irgendwie AFD Schleswig-Holstein ihre Leute noch Demo Geld zahlen wollte ne 50 € demogeld wenn du Zeit die Großdemonstration fährst und das war dann ja also einige wenige.
1000 Hanseln von der AFD die dann da einmal vom Hauptbahnhof zum Brandenburger Tor gegangen sind mit ihren Deutschland fahren.
Und eine also ich weiß nicht wann ich das letzte Mal so eine große Demo in Berlin gesehen habe.
Es gab diese was war denn die letzte große ich glaube das war das so eine ttip demo.
Die war das glaube ich na die so irgendwie Einrichtung 100000 gegen oder so ist ein paar Jahre her weil wenn ich mich nicht täusche die letzte sehr große Demo in Berlin.
In Wien auch die ttip Demo ceta Demo ist das waren die wirklich großen und das bis jetzt auch nichts mehr angekommen.
Diese Demo ich war da also ich meine ich wohne in dieser Stadt.
Sie selten den 17juni komplett voll er was.
Bis auf das letzte Stück wo es eben gesperrt war ich bin echt nicht gut im Zählen von Menschenmengen so.
Aber die offizielle Zahl von der Polizei dass es sich um 25000.
Gegendemonstranten und Demonstranten gehandelt haben soll.
Die auch von den Medien sehr viel übernommen wurde die kann ich mir schwer vorstellen weil ich zu der Menge 25.000 Personen nämlich eine Referenz habe und das ist ungefähr.
Na ja so ein Fußballstadion von Union oder San pauli essen da sind ungefähr 25.000 Leute drin.
Und da muss ich sagen war das dann doch um einiges mehr was da demonstriert hat so ich so andere haben ja.
Auf bis zu 75 oder 72.000 geschätzt.
Da glaube ich ohne mich festlegen zu wollen würde ich sagen da waren auf jeden Fall eher 75125,
also sparen auf jeden Fall mehr als 25000 wie viel besser kann ich kann ich nicht zählen ob das jetzt doppelt so viele waren wie in so einem Stadion sind oder dreimal das kann man glaube ich eben auch aus einer Perspektive nicht so gut sehen,
ich bin nur einmal halt vorgegangen und habe dann so den ganzen Zug an mir vorbeigehen lassen und das war halt.
Massiv viel und der 17. Juni ist eine relativ breite Straße,
und das war ja nicht die einzige Gegendemo also war das war echt eine eine geile Sache daran hat ihm weiß nicht wie viele Wagen endlich wieder alte Berliner Loveparade Zeiten so das war schon wirklich eine.
Sehr geiles Ding was da gestartet ist und hat große Freude gemacht so.
Am zum Thema bezahlte Demonstrationen und Antifaschismus verlinken wir in der Stelle jetzt noch nicht kennt von Helmut Qualtinger der Herr Karl Gustostück der österreichischen Kultur Seele und erklärt dieses Land sehr gut an der Karl ist jemand der irgendwie jeden,
Beispiel Österreicher der durch den Zweiten Weltkrieg gelebt hat darstellt und zu Helmut Qualtinger war sowieso einer der besten und des das Verlinken wir werden nicht,
gesehen hat sollte sich das auf jeden Fall anschauen.
Ich bitte darum ich glaube diese diese demogeld Nummer warum wir da so drüber Scherzen ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so klar ist ist ein,
eine sehr beständige Verschwörungstheorie dieser NPD und AFD Anhänger,
das ist irgendwie einen Antifa e.v. gebe der den,
der bei linken Demonstrationen Demo Geld zahlt und also die Linken Menschen quasi dorthin bestellt und die irgendwie für die Demonstration Style name bezahlt relativ,
relativ amüsanter Humbug,
der natürlich dadurch noch schöner wird dass die AFD das tatsächlich tut zu ihrer Großdemo die sie ja ursprünglich mit 10.000 angekündigt hatten und dann nachher schon mal runtergeschnitten hatten auf 5000 was.
Was echt massiv traurig ist für die AFD ich finde es natürlich sehr schön aber lassen wir das.
Die AFD AFD ddlme Einhorn Standarte hat auf jeden Fall auch da geliefert.
Wann kommen wir zum ersten Thema.
Na ich war noch eine gute eine gute eine gute Nachricht noch kurz verbringen Job hast du gerade kurz übersprungen und das ist das Bundes Fasnet ist jetzt sicher.
Das also gute Nachrichten das Bundestags nett ist jetzt sicher woher wissen wir das weil es meine Webseite sperrt.
Die Gedichte die Story wie das zustande Kabel ist eigentlich sehr oder wie wir diese Informationen erlangt haben war eigentlich ganz ganz nett und darf erzählt werden und zwar ist es eine,
Mitarbeiterin im Deutschen Bundestag gewesen die das festgestellt hat selbstverständlich muss ja jemand sein der im Deutschen Bundestag arbeitet.
Und die war auf der Suche nach meiner Stellungnahme zum IT Sicherheitsgesetz.
Am atlas.at Sicherheitsgesetz vor ein paar Jahren verabschiedet wurde habe ich da ja als Sprecher des Chaos Computer Club eine Stellungnahme zu abgegeben und die.
Zu finden war jetzt das Ziel dieser Bundestag.
Mitarbeiterin und jetzt ist es eigentlich kein kein schlechtes Geheimnis da keinen besonders gut gehütetes Geheimnis dass die.
Die Bundestagsdrucksachen die der Bundestag irgendwie dann da anfertigen lässt und ihr Vieh online stellt ungefähr so.
Chaotisch die publiziert werden wie irgendwas in der ARD Mediathek das ist da immer eine Zeitlang aber die haben.
Hoffen wir auf der bundestag.de Seite den fehlt irgendwie ein sinnvolles Konzept dafür dass es jetzt einen neuen Bundestag gibt.
Ja und und einen neuen neue Ausschüsse und neue Anhörung und der Ausschuss ist jetzt anders besetzt und so weiter was zur Folge hat.
Dass sie regelmäßig nach einer Wahl einen größeren Teil der früher online gestellten Inhalte irgendwie.
Entweder wirklich ganz rausnehmen oder zumindest so weg bewegen dass man den nicht mehr wiederfindet und jetzt war also diese Mitarbeiterin auf der Suche nach meiner Stellungnahme und hat festgestellt ok auf bundestag.de finde ich das nicht mehr obwohl es die damals natürlich,
dort gab und hat dann gesagt nicht okay dann google ich die eben und hat natürlich dann meinen meine Webseite getroffen und Linus Neumann de,
ist im Bundestag seine jetzt gesperrt und zwar aus Sicherheitsgründen aber nichts Fracht hat sich natürlich.
Was ist ist auf meiner Webseite das irgendwie den Bundestag verunsichern könnten.
Dummerweise bekommt man da keine Auskunft und ich bin mir jetzt noch nicht so ganz sicher wie ich darauf reagieren werde weil.
Ist ja schon relativ witzig ist dass ich als Sachverständiger in den Bundestag geladen werde dort eine Stellungnahme formuliere.
Und die die ersten von bundestag.de löschen und zweitens im Bundestag meine Webseite schweren also da so meine Kleine sperren was sie wollen für mich persönlich ist das ja nur Fame,
wenn die mich sperren aber für die Arbeit die ich da irgendwie als Sachverständiger geleistet habe ist das ja tatsächlich ne.
Ja ne also was erlaube Bundestags oder alles so sehe ich mir meine stell ich mir mein Engagement da nicht vor.
Das wenn an interessierte MdBs und deren MitarbeiterInnen,
sag ok was war denn damals der Diskussion stand ja was hat denn da was wunderfrage Momente vorgetragen oder nicht dass das dann den Bundestag nicht mehr zugänglich ist also ziemlich meine Vorstellung von.
Wie dieser parlamentarische Prozess irgendwie abzulaufen hat muss ich mal schauen ob und wie man da diese Sperrliste.
Wie man darunter kommt oder wie man die man sehen kann die werden sie natürlich auch geheim halten ich muss mal gucken wann ich Zeit habe da mal irgendwie eine IFG Anfrage zu stellen oder mich mehr Info zu beklagen oder so weiß noch nicht genau wie ich damit umgehe.
IFG Anfrage machen und auch Datenschutz Auskunft gleich am heulen weil da muss ich ja nackter zugeben da muss er eben von meiner Entscheidung getroffen worden sein welche Webseite zu sperren sind und nachdem deiner Webseite ja deinen Namen beinhaltet,
was vielleicht darüber Datenschutz Schiene probieren ob man da was rausfindet.
Dsgvo to the rescue.
Vielleicht kann ich dir ja abmachen.
Wir kommen zur zur dsgvo kommen wir gleich jetzt, zu dem wichtigen Thema eines dass wir das jetzt siedendheiß ist und dass wir nämlich einige Zeit nicht mehr.
Behandelt haben und jetzt jetzt beißt uns auf einmal in den Allerwertesten oder ist kurz da.
Natürlich um das eigentlich besorgniserregend der EU gesetzt und das derzeit im Backofen ist die neue UEFA rechts Richtlinie und da drinnen.
Die vorgeschriebenen upload-filter und das Leistungsschutzrecht auf europäischer Ebene wir haben darüber schon mehrmals berichtet wir hatten ja auch schon Julia Rehder hier im Podcast dazu und jetzt ist einiges passiert.
Also a der Rat haben also grundsätzlich wir erinnern uns es ist an.
EU Gesetz eine Richtlinie die das neue Urheberrecht regeln soll und da drinnen gibt es eben,
vorgeschriebene upload-filter so jede Plattform die user-generated-content hat muss eben solche upload-filter Zensur Filter,
am einbauen,
Abzw wahrscheinlich die nicht selbst entwickeln sondern von Kugel sich Content-ID in die eigene Plattform einbauen und dann wird sozusagen jede kulturelle Äußerung in Europa egal ob Videobild Audio oder 8 Uhr,
gegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen vorab geprüft und wenn dieser Filter deine batbox ist jetzt sagt entscheidend dieser Inhalt nicht.
Wer hat uns bewertungssumme sign getrennt dass es auch wieder so ein Oettinger spät er aber ne.
Kommissar der Herzen Günther Oettinger der das mithilfe von Axel Springer und anderen auf den Weg gebracht hat und ja,
hat das ziemlich ähnlich gut aufgestellt ist auch der Berichterstatter zu diesem gesetzt das ist der Axel Voss von der Union auch einen besonders,
darf der Politiker der sich komplett frei von allen Fakten bewegen kann und ja in diesem.
Kind immer vor leider sehr viel Einfluss hat als Berichterstatter im europäischen Prozess spricht er sozusagen für das gesamte Parlament und treibt jetzt auch den Prozess innerhalb des Parlaments mal zu einer Meinung zu kommen zwar ist der.
Es ist zwar ganz klar schon gesagt worden.
H&M Kollektion Abkommen in Deutschland das upload-filter eigentlich gar nicht geht und dass man das extrem problematisch hält,
trotzdem steht das hier in diesem Gesetz Trainern und und was treibt das gerade voran ja.
Zweite Thema Leistungsschutzrecht 40 Männer hatten im Begriff sein gibt's ja in Deutschland schon gibt es auch in Spanien in beiden Ländern ist es gescheitert,
der Sohn hat nicht dazu geführt dass es irgendwie mehr Geld an Zeitungen geflossen wäre und schon alles der Inhalte irgendwie von Google finanziert würden sondern Google-News gibt's.
Eigentlich immer noch Zulassung Deutschland und die Konkurrenten von Google News andere Aggregatoren sind vom Markt gefegt worden.
Es war quasi also das Ergebnis des Klappe weil das beides ein bisschen komplexer Themen sind wie ich das nur ganz kurz zusammenfassen das Leistungsschutzrecht sollte ja quasi sagen ok der Verlag nicht er.
Nicht die die Autorin sondern der Verlag hat jetzt ein ein ein quasi ein Urheber.
Rechtzeitiges recht an seinen Erzeugnissen und dieses Recht,
zu treten soll er quasi dann gegen Geld tun mit dem mit dem mit dem Wunsch die Idee war damals oder das Argument war immer da.
Netedy Zeitungssterben weil alle nur noch Google News lesen und Google News nimmt den ganzen ganzen ganzen Content kostenlos.
Und mach damit ein Schweinegeld guck mal die sind alle ganz Reich bei Google das war also die die Argumentation und dann hatten wurde quasi gesagt ja okay wir wollen jetzt durch dieses Leistungsschutzrecht erreichen.
Dass die Verlage Google Geld dafür abnehmen können dass sie ihre Inhalt dass Google ihre Inhalte bei Google News nutzt.
Und so wird dann dieser wird dann eben hier Gerechtigkeit entstehen ne das war die Argumentation,
was ist passiert nachdem das Gesetz verabschiedet wurde haben alle Verlage unisono sofort gesagt ok Google bitte schön hier habt ihr einen schrieb in dem wir euch gegenüber erklären,
dass ihr das hier auf die Durchsetzung Leistungsschutzrecht Licher Ansprüche gegenüber euch verzichten und euch und bitte bitte bitte.
Lass unsere Seiten auf diesen auf diesem Google News drauf weil von euch kommen ja 25% von unseren Traffic dann sie auch noch laut gequengelt weil sie bei Google ja glaube ich irgendwie als dieses Gesetz dann.
Verabschiedet wurde oder in Kraft getreten ist ein Tag gesagt hat ach so okay sorry an Gesetze halten wir uns natürlich.
Wir machen das mal kurz aus ne wir wir machen Google News aus und dann waren sie am quengeln und sagt niemand will mir unsere Zeitung lesen bitte bitte bitte bitte,
kommt wieder drauf sodass Fall zu kurz zusammengefasst die Geschichte ist Leistungsschutzrecht in Deutschland oder.
Genau und in Spanien ist es eh nicht verlaufen da ist die Regierung dann noch ein Schritt weiter gegangen und hatte versucht eine Verpflichtung einzuführen also Google dazu zu zwingen diese Inhalte von.
Den Verlagen zu lizensieren also sozusagen sie wollte noch mal ein Gesetz machen das wirklich Google dazu zwingt ihr müsst dieses Produkt jetzt von diesen ganzen Verlagen von unserem Land kaufen mit dem Effekt dass Google News in Spanien abgeschalten wurde.
Was auch.
Google halt am Arsch vorbei gegangen oder also der hat was die verdienen doch kein Geld mit diesem Google News oder.
Ja ich meine neue Sachen bin so ja man könnte sagen das ist ja auch in die Suchresultate geht und dort schalten Sie Werbung und darüber verdienen sie nicht.
Geld aber im Zweifelsfall ich und wir sehen uns jetzt doch auch bei Facebook durch die ganze Debatte TS hoch kocht wo wo auch irgendwie sagerberg,
langsam merkt dass es enger wird findet zumindest in meinen Jungs wisst ganz subjektiv viel weniger journalistische Inhalte.
Es ist wird einfach generell der Fokus verschiebt sich ein bisschen und du hast halt einfach weniger Nachrichten du nimmst von dem Content die als Kategorie problematisch sein könnte einfach prozentuell nur noch weniger rein.
Und für Google wäre das dann eben einfach das Abschalten von Google News oder eben nur noch mit der Kneifzange journalistische Inhalte überhaupt in in den Index zu übernehmen was einer faktenbasiert mit der Butt,
auch sicherlich nicht hilfreich wäre also dieser wir haben so ein Trend der Zeit es gibt eine extreme Regulierung Hunger in der,
Altmann will irgendwie Google und Facebook mit Gesetzen irgendwie an die Kandare nehmen aber was man erreicht es eigentlich dass man Gesetze macht die genau für diese Plattformen überhaupt kein Problem darstellen.
Aber für alle anderen für die Konkurrenten für das Netz an sich und die Kind in die Zentrale Charakter Teens immer noch hat zumindest oktorail für das sind das Supergau,
weil da mit Hürden geschaffen werden die für keinen Konkurrenten oder Mitbewerber mehr zu erfüllen sind oder wenn du nicht zu groß bist wie die begreift dann wird es einfach wahnsinnig schwierig noch an erfolgreichen Dienst.
Sportverein wenn der RV Zuspruch aus der Community von den Nutzern selber angewiesen ist.
Ein Argument das ja auch immer wieder im Rahmen der dsgvo.
Genannt wird nur dass man sagt ja so die regulierungs Anforderungen sind am Ende so stark und so hoch,
dass die Konkurrenz im Keim ersticken sodass eigentlich quasi eine etablierte Industrie im Prinzip ein Interesse haben kann daran dass sie schön fett reguliert wird,
damit weil sie weiß dass sie ihn dann quasi innovativer innovative spontane Konkurrenz einfach nicht entsteht.
Bei der dsgvo also das Argument ansich teilig schauen aber ich glaube nicht dass es bei der dsgvo so unmittelbar zu treffen ist zwei Gründen erstens.
Der ist geht ja wirklich um Grundrecht dass es geht ja nur um die die simplen Spielregeln wie dieses Grundrecht ab zuzusichern ist und in Wirklichkeit ist er es ist ein neuer Aufwand der Sinn steht.
Aber der ist direkt proportional mit den personenbezogenen Daten gespeichert.
Und wenn du wenn du auch ein kleines Unternehmen bist oder geiler Verein aber du hast das irgendwie weiß nicht nehmen wir an das Rote Kreuz würde TNA Datenbanken machen z.b.
wer wäre auch etwas wo man sich denkt ja das sind hochsensible Daten und auch wenn ihr alles gut meint und wenn ihr irgendwie gemeinnützig seid trotzdem,
das sind sensible Daten da müssen höhere Anforderungen.
Kommen an insofern dieser Riese Co-Abhängige Ansatz der in der dsgvo drinnen ist der der ist an sich,
glaube ich schon der richtige und das hätte man auch nicht besser schreiben können und ja,
aber an sich natürlich also was wir wir reden die ganze Zeit nur über die großen Plattformen und das Gesetz wenn es so kommen würde fahren die upload-filter heißen halt einfach das WordPress Kinder TripAdvisor,
Mieterbund Verein eben auch die Wikipedia vor massiver Probleme gestellt werden also entweder du lizenziert dir dann Content-ID.
Oder aber dabei music hat die zwei upload-filter die's so gibt in der Welt oder du stehst einfach vor einem nicht zu tragenden Haftungsrisiko.
Also das ist ja die die Grunde seines von diesem Gesetz einfach du hast diese Zensuren versucht Uhr oder du bist immer in der Haftung für jede Urheberrechtsverletzung die deine Nutzer bei dir begehen an das kann man eigentlich nicht schultern.
Ja aber was ist jetzt eigentlich passiert.
Ja der Rat also die EU-Mitgliedstaaten haben jetzt am 15.Mai ihre Position gefunden.
Und die ist wie zu erwarten war leider eine sehr schlechte sowohl Abluftfilter wie auch Leistungsschutzrecht finden sich in dem Text auf den sich die Mitgliedstaaten geeinigt haben,
und ja Deutschland hat lustigerweise im Rat gegen diese Einigung gestimmt.
Weil ihnen die upload-filter zu hart war aber auch weil ihnen das Leistungsschutzrecht nicht scharf genug war.
Also ganz lustige Gründe für uns ist das immer so das grauenvolle gesetzte ist gibt aber sehr unterschiedliche Mehrheiten bei beiden gehen.
Gegen waren außerdem auch noch Ungarn die auch noch mehr Leistungsschutzrecht gerne gehabt hätten Belgien Niederlande Slowenien und Finnland.
Also das sind sozusagen die die formal dagegen gestimmt haben.
Und es gibt aber eben gerade bei diesem Upload Filtern ist ist Großbritannien immer noch ganz stark dafür,
weil dann sieht man schon so ein bisschen dafür dass diese upload-filter wenn sie mal installiert sind dann natürlich auch für terroristische Inhalte und juristische theologisch geprägte Inhalte verwendet werden können,
das ist so der nächste Schritt zu wenn dieses Gesetz so kommt es wird nicht beim Urheberrecht bleiben sondern wenn man so eine Infos Doktor mal hat wird man die auch für andere Dinge verwenden es gab schon mal so einen Vorschlag.
Adia EU Anti Terror Richtlinie hat er in ihrer ursprünglichen Fassung auch Upload Filter für terroristische Inhalte und das ist im Europaparlament aber rausgestrichen worden.
Jetzt da merke ich dass du dann doch österreichischen Fokus hast denn genau diesen.
Genau das mit dem Terror da da haben wir jetzt hängt der Seehofer schon,
in den Seilen aller der der der sieht schon in den in den Startlöchern und hat jetzt gesagt hier hat einen Brief formuliert an die EU-Kommission und hat gesagt hier wir wollen eine gesetzliche Regelung um terrorpropaganda,
zu rauszuwerfen also genau das also wieder genau das gleiche also die die Geschichten der Netzpolitik kennen wir ja inzwischen also Deutschland ist da mal wieder,
Vorreiter dass ich den Eindruck.
Erweiterter ist schon so ein übergeordnetes narrativ dahinter also es ist ich habe die Politik will halt einfach dieses Internet wieder unter Kontrolle bringen die haben gemerkt so,
zu viel zu viele verschiedene Stimmen und soviel Dezentralität zu Kontrollverlust auch bei den mächtigen und deswegen wir brauchen neue Kontrollinstrumente.
Und das Urheberrecht ist jetzt hier der Türöffner aber es wird wirklich nicht dort bleiben und umso.
Was was ist zufolge hat für diese diese also wenn ich das richtig verstanden haben soll wird ja eigentlich gesagt also es ist.
Klar dass man dass es dass diese das upload-filter zum Leben zum overblocking führen werden,
ja vor allem wenn man so anbringt deswegen haben sie,
quasi in die auch in dieser neuen in diesen neuen ECU Gesetzesvorschlag dass er darüber gewusst dass sie dass sie nicht sagen du musst filtern.
Nein nein sondern sie sagen du hast es halt.
Na das ist ja also quasi der das Gesetz schreibt ja nicht vor ihr müsst einen upload-filter haben sondern steht halt einfach drin wenn er irgendetwas rechts.
Prächtig problematisches ist habt ihr dafür fertig die Konsequenz daraus ist natürlich dass die upload-filter brauchen,
aber da steht jetzt quasi nicht direkt drin.
Nehme im Rat Pack.
Also im Rat 6 ist es wirklich so also du kommerzielle Plattformen sind immer in der Haftung für alle oben rechts Verletzungen außer sie haben Filter und wenn du einen Filter hast.
Dann ist es egal welche urbe Rechtsverletzungen auf deiner Plattform stattfinden ist immer straffrei.
Das heißt was da geschrieben wird es ist eins zu eins die Wishlist von YouTube.
Weil gern fehlt der hat ja auch seine Probleme funktionieren ja nicht wirklich immer.
Es gibt ganz viele Videos die die nicht erkannt was geht falsch positiv es gibt ganz viele Kollateralschäden aber das ist ihnen an der Stelle wurscht.
Also Container die mit all seine Macken wird hier legalisiert und das führt einfach so einer Situation wo kein Urheber irgendwie in Cent mehr sieht aber die Filter die wir jetzt hier bei den großen Plattformen haben werden einen anderen.
Aufgeschrieben und verpflichtend gemacht,
also es ist wirklich eine lose lose lose Situation außer ich mit einem kurzen Plattformen gegen die man eigentlich vorgehen wollte also ich kann auch nicht vorstellen dass es irgendwie kreativer gibt,
die die sich das wünschen werden die irgendwie sagen so mir ist jeder Remix egal,
mir ist Zitatrecht egal politische Parodie egal Bildung Schranke egal dass dir um die fallen wir alle um nur dass ich irgendwie sicher gehen kann dass das diese Technologie überall eingesetzt wird.
Arm und ja also das ganze ist wie schon jemals gesagt hat meiner Meinung nach das problematisch der gesetzt was ist derzeit gibt.
Und wir stehen jetzt ungefähr fünf vor 12 Uhr in der Debatte dazu nachdem der Rat jetzt eine Position gefällt hat.
Hängt alles nur noch Ameropa Parlament und dort.
Und zwar im liege Leffers komm mit IRS office.
Juri Rechtsausschuss der wird abstimmen über dieses Gesetz am 20. Juni also schon sehr bald und im Moment schaut es so aus dass 12 zu 13.
Als einem Jahr hat für upload-filter ge.
Also man müsste theoretisch ein rechnerisch nur einen Abgeordneten einer Abgeordnete drehen damit man das ganze umdrehen kann ich meine es ist immer die Gefahr dass die Sozialdemokraten umfallen.
Hat die Gefahr ja ja das ist.
Arm und deswegen der der große Aufruf ist jetzt hier irgendwie mit der Politik ins Gespräch zu kommen es gibt natürlich wieder eine Kampagnen Webseite save your internet.lu.
Ist da die Webseite die wir verlinken werden und die von allen Organisationen gerade gepusht wird also von e3dc FF alle verlinken dort gerade alle sind gerade up in Arms weil die nächsten paar Tage sind,
das entscheidende und.
Und was kann man bei dieser Seite tun wie kann die LMP Einhorn Standarte hier tätig werden.
Also an die aller sinnvollste effizienteste Variante abgeordnet zu überzeugen ist zum Hörer zu greifen und dort anzurufen.
A es gibt call Tools auf dieser Webseite man kann aber auch einfach auf der Website des Europaparlaments sich die Büro Nummern von Brüssel und von Straßburg von den Abgeordneten holen und.
Anrufen und einfach als Bürgerin aus Bürgerrat vorsprechen und sagen hier ich habe hier ein großes Problem mit diesem Gesetz das ist es mit,
meine maurischen werden nicht vereinbart das wäre schlecht für unsere Wirtschaft das ist schlecht für die Meinungsfreiheit das hilft den Urhebern nicht die wollen nämlich entlohnt werden für ihre Werke und nicht dass sie gelöscht werden,
und das muss man einfach den Abgeordneten klarmachen es hilft aber auch nicht die Institutionen zu gehen.
Arm und dieses Jahr wenn man in den welchen Ortsverbänden ist wenn man Unternehmen hat als Unternehmen dort wirklich mal vorzusprechen gerade stehen und aus der Wirtschaft sind bei so,
Binnenmarkt Themen ganz wichtig und halt einfach auch wirklich die die nationalen Parteien in die Verantwortung nehmen.
Also von den Sozialdemokraten gibt's nur so zwei drei die sich bis jetzt auf einem Brief gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht unterschrieben haben die meisten sind da still,
am die die FDP müsste mal in ihrer Fraktion aufräumen auf Europaebene weil die die Liberalen im Europaparlament sind da gespalten.
Also von denen 67 Abgeordneten die die haben im Parlament sind nur 25 gegen diese Gesetze das heißt die Mehrzahl der Liberalen stellt sich hier klar gegen die Freiheit und da müsste man eigentlich nur bei Druck innerhalb der Fraktion machen.
Ja und die Konservativen die Europäische Volkspartei sind am 10 für diese Verschärfungen.
Und mit dem Berichterstatter Axel Voss der von der Union kommt auch am meisten verantwortlich dafür was in diesen Gesetzen steht und gerade nachdem,
der Koalitionsvertrag in Deutschland wenigsten sagt wir wollen keine upload-filter kann man die auch wirklich mal in die Pflicht nehmen und eigentlich müsste man in der Union den Post zurückpfeifen und irgendwie mal,
bisschen in der Debatte führen die die wieder näher an den Fakten ist.
Was für eine Debatte führen die eigentlich wenn also wenn sie in einem Abwasch sagen hier der Google der ist schlecht und deswegen soll der Google in Zukunft über alles über alle Inhalte richten.
Welche also das ist ja beides in einem Paket hier ne also Leistungsschutzrecht unveräußerlich übrigens will will Axel Voss das ja auch haben ne das heißt man die die Lady Verlage dürfen nicht mehr nicht mitspielen.
Und gleich in innen gleichen.
Also der hat doch beides auf zwei DIN A4 auf einer DIN A4 Seite zu Hause liegen auf dem Tisch und sieht doch also welchen Teil sehen die so anders das sieht nicht merken dass.
Define die Hälfte der Leute dort nicht merkt dass sie was sie da tun also dass es auch in sich kohärent allein schon widersprüchlich ist.
Also sind nähere Sachen also die Debatte zum Leistungsschutzrecht ist das der eh schon vorher dargestellt so.
Google Google verdient ja Geld wir verdienen weniger Geld Google gib uns Geld und wir schaffen einfach neue Berichte und irgendwie kannst das Nippes wie Merkel trifft Trump auf einmal monetarisieren zu können.
Ganz egal was die Kollateralschäden sind bei Upload fehlt dann ist die Argumentation der Gegenseite der sogenannte value gap also das ist auch eine komische aber mit der Zion die sich mir auch nichts,
NC ganz erschließt aber die Logik geht ungefähr so wenn ich ein Musikstück auf spotify mir anhöre dann kriege ich da irgendwie Betrag X und wenn ich es mir auf YouTube anhören dann kriege ich nur Betrag y der ist kleiner an diesem value gap zwischen den verschiedenen Nutzungsformen,
er hat auch darin besteht dass ihm nicht alles aus urheberrechtlich geschützt ist auch acantis und entlohnt wird und in den Verträgen die.
YouTube Jan zwischen hart mit der GEMA und mit den Rechteverwerter die Zahlen ja schon für die kreativen Werke wir wissen nicht wie viel weil die Verträge sind geheim.
Aber man sagt sozusagen ja wenn wir da technisch überall noch diese Filter haben und mit 10 kann dann wird es gerechter dann dann wird dieser value gap kleiner das ist die,
Argumentation die man auch hört wenn man mit konservativen spricht wenn man Emails schickt z.b. kann man auch machen über save your internet. EU kriegt man eigentlich immer noch so diese Standard.
Antworten zurückhaben und E-Mails sind ein sehr ineffizient das weg mit Abgeordneten in Kontakt zu treten.
Sinnvollste sagen für dich das anrufen.
Kann das aber auch kombinieren also zuerst eine e-mail schicken und dann irgendwie ein paar Tage später anrufen das ist die aller effizienteste oder professionelles der Art und Weise social media.
Alle diese Abgeordneten haben heutzutage Facebook und Twitter profile dort kann man ihnen auch schreiben möglichst öffentlich das hilft auch.
Und natürlich auch wirklich auf die Parteien an sich einfach nehmen also die Europaabgeordneten,
hängen ja auch an ihr Mandat und müssen aufgestellt werden uns werden da auch wenn man irgendwie über eine Ortskurve oder über die die in Deutschland verheirateten zugtouren geht.
Auch mitbekommen dass es dazu.
Insgesamt spricht hat gegen uns das wegen dem Leistungsschutzrecht viele Verlage eben gerade nicht sehr.
Detailliert berichten über diese Dinge da geht halt um Eigeninteresse.
Vor allem ein sehr starkes Medium in Brüssel ist ja politico Europe Axel Springer hat da große Beteiligungen dran deswegen schreiben die so gut wie gar nichts und wenn dann nur sehr positiv über diese Gesetze die Kritik kommt einfach nicht vor.
Am uns gesehen jetzt aber trotzdem schon,
dr simpel Brecht dass er gerade Ärztin in dieser Woche gab es die ersten BBC Geschichten über upload-filter ich glaube es ab,
bringt jetzt dann auch noch was vor der Abstimmung mit Julia Reda also es ist wirklich schon bissel,
vorab berichtet was gut ist weil normalerweise kriegen die Leute nicht mit was in Brüssel für Gesetze gemacht werden und merken dann irgendwie zwei Jahre später wenn das nationale Gesetz da ist.
Was da eigentlich passiert ist und was das für Sie bedeutet dann ist es aber zu spät wir haben jetzt gerade noch diese paar Tage bis zum 20 Juni.
Wenn der Rechtsausschuss abstimmt das ist unsere große Chance das Ding noch zu verhindern wenn das im Rechtsausschuss schaffen.
Dann hat das Parlament eine gute Meinung und dann haben wir gehen wir mit einer guten Position in den Trilog es gibt da noch die Abstimmung im Plenum.
Das ist die aller aller letzte Chance das ist aber um einiges schwieriger im Rechtsausschuss haben wir so ungefähr 30 Abgeordnete die entscheiden werden mit denen wir reden müssen.
Und im Plenum gibt's 751 die abstimmen werden da drüber.
Was ist da ist es viel unvorhersehbarer und da braucht man natürlich noch viel viel mehr Energie und darum diese Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen deswegen ist es ganz wichtig jetzt noch was zu tun.
Onza daneben,
wecke ich auch Kreativität ist gefordert einfach nur über dieses Thema zu sprechen aber vielleicht das auf die Webseite einzubauen auf meine Briefe gibt es für Unternehmen die man unterzeichnen kann Eigengrund müssen wir eigentlich alles tun.
Als Einhorn stand hat was was uns irgendwie einfällt um das jetzt noch zu verhindern aber ich kenne solche kompan in den letzten Metern wenn sie es noch diesen kreativen,
wenn es von allen Seiten auf einmal Leute aufstehen dann können wir das auch wirklich noch verhindern nur es muss halt jetzt wirklich in den nächsten Tagen passieren.
Also liebe Einhorn Standarte Internettelefonie ist modern und gut save your internet. EU den Link findet ihr auch in den Shownotes von Julia Reda.
Haben wir auch die beiden entscheidenden Blogpost die wie immer von hoher Qualität sind es sehr genau auch noch mal die inhaltlichen.
Punkte und Kritikpunkte zusammenfassen selfio Internet EU ist es natürlich auch der Fall und dann ruft er einfach mal in Europa an in diesem Fall bei.
Den Abgeordneten die.
Das jetzt noch verhindern können dass das Parlament mit dieser Position in den Trilog geht denn die Kommission hat ja sowieso schon eine Position die daneben auch in diese Richtung geht und da müssen wir.
Jetzt einschreiten wunderbar.
Dann kommen wir zum nächsten Thema das hatte ich gerade schon kurz angedeutet.
Der Terror Horst.
Der Terror Horst der hat schon an die EU-Kommission geschrieben nicht nur er sondern die Innenminister hört man den französischen Innenminister drücken oder zugenommen und hat gesagt hier Facebook Twitter und Co sollen innerhalb von,
einer Stunde Inhalte löschen.
Bei terrorpropaganda natürlich denken wir auch darüber nach dass auszuweiten über alles andere und gemacht was uns im Internet nicht gefällt und sagen also Inhalt einer Stunde müssen sie entfernt werden.
Damit nicht damit nichts virales entstehen kann.
Ihr kennt diese ganzen viral gehen den Terror memes die euch jeden Tag in die Hände von Terroristen führen außerdem möchte er.
Quasi Statistiken darüber haben dass die Unternehmen.
Kann ich Statistiken ausgeben und sagen hier das und dass er mal entfernt und so weiter.
Und irgendwie dann eine gemeinsame Datenbank mit mit Hash Werten irgendwie pflegen sollen sonst zusammenarbeiten und dann sagt er uns ist schon klar dass jetzt die kleinen Unternehmen das nicht hinkriegen,
deswegen,
sollen die großen Unternehmen die kleinen unterstützen also genau wie der das das Ding ne dass man sagt ok natürlich kriegt der kriegt das kleine.
Soziale Netzwerk das nicht hin deswegen sollen die einfach irgend kompletten Konten von Google oder sonst nehmen filtern lassen oder Facebook ne das muss man sich ja auch nur mal vorstellen dass.
Wenn man jetzt sagt was weiß ich folgendes ist ein nicht gewünscht der Inhalt ja oder oder.
Folgende was weiß ich die Kommentare von Logbuch Netzpolitik unterliegen ab jetzt dem Urheberrechts und terrorpropaganda Filter von Google,
ja dann bedeutet das dass ihr alle unsere alle eure Kommentare zu unseren Sendungen bei denen ging die Datenbank prüfen müssen ja.
Und jetzt ist es ja nicht so als wäre terrorpropaganda,
irgendwie etwas was ich was ich hessbar abbilden lässt oder so na das kann ja kann sich ja ändern das und so Terror Kommentar die ihr ja teilweise nervöser Kommentar hinterlassen könntet,
das müssten wir ja natürlich alles an Google schieben alles also quasi ich weiß ich man fragt sich ernsthaft was die für eine.
Was die für einen.
Ja
Die sich dabei denken.
Ja und dass dass dass das Richtige ist ja auch wie solche Filter dann wirklich in der in der Praxis funktionieren also das ist ja nicht nur ein simpler Abgleich von von 2 Hash werden sondern.
Content-ID und auch foto-id was du heute habe ich schon mal hier erklärt hast diese System.
Auch schonmal falsch erklärt habe.
Aber.
Na ich habe es einmal falsch erklärt dann wurden wir in den Kommentaren sehr genau darauf hingewiesen wie diese Verfahren funktioniert war sehr interessant dann habe ich noch mal richtig erklären.
Genau das hätte dir dieser dass das wiederum wenn ich aber was wichtig ist dass da wirklich in die Dateien hineingeschaut wert.
Bonsai eine eine komplette Prüfung gemacht wird also Content-ID erkennt auch das Lady Gaga Lied was irgendwo in der Mitte von meinem Heimvideo vorkommt.
Also die schauen wirklich in den Content hinein und.
Aber diese Filter sind nicht perfekt das ist ganz wichtig zu sagen wenn da auch mal was falsch erkannt wird da gibt's immer wieder Fälle der schönste war.
Letztens irgendwie bei der irischen abtreibungs compagnia gab es irgendwie Frauennetzwerk die so ein,
Kampagnen wieder gehabt haben wo sie sich eben gegen diese,
hat für die Abschaffung des Abtreibungsverbot Zeit ausgesprochen haben die waren total erfolgreich amstern ins Fernsehen geschafft da ist Ihr Video ausgestrahlt worden am nächsten Tag war das 4 video.
Ja weil es natürlich jetzt das Urheberrecht von diesem Fernsehsender war.
Fernsehen.
An erst recht dass es so Urheberrecht geht noch einigermaßen da hast du irgendwie ein Werk und dann anderes Werk und.
Vielleicht kannst du das erkennen aber bitte schön was ist terrorpropaganda ey Mann das ist ist ist es so ein schwammiger,
Begriff heutzutage weil wir ja auch in der aus Verhandlung stehen,
wo es geht um gesellschaftliche rein da die sich radikalisieren und es geht um terroristische Straftaten aber die Ideologie dahinter ist so schwer greifbar und auch so einer Veränderung unterworfen die ganze Zeit,
Überlegung wert.
Da diese kanarischen Anschläge z.b. jetzt wie ist das incels dieser mir fällt der Begriff jetzt nicht an die.
Wo geht dieser eine Anschlag der auch von jemanden verübt wurde der Teil von so einer Online-Community war die sozusagen weil sie keinen Sex bekommen und weiß sie sich zurück gestellt haben sondern keine Verschwörungstheorie und da gab es jetzt schon zwei Anschläge,
dazu die diesem Spektrum zuzuordnen sind wirst auch den Fehler tourismusforscher sagen das ist eigentlich in der Schulbuch Definition,
genau das wie wir sonst wäre es muss festmachen aber wir haben ganz großes Bauchgefühl das jetzt hier sozusagen weil weil es uns in ganz schwierige Fragestellungen Braig,
also ich sag mir das Ideologie im Internet algorithmisch zu regulieren ist das Fass also.
Also Massen geht natürlich ganz einfach du machst halt irgendwie,
da machst du halt was mit machine learning und dann tut das so und dann hat das seine alpha und Beta Fehler lässt also ab und zu mal was durch und,
Overblog dann die ganze Zeit und jedes Mal wenn et wenn es mal was durchgelassen hast reduzierst du wieder den alpha-fehler zugunsten des beta-fehler so mit anderen Worten dann am Ende over blockst du halt alles ne aber okay brauchen wir glaube ich gar nicht mehr so viel weiter ausführen spannend finde ich das Seehofer ja auch noch sagt ja wir brauchen vor allem auch Sanktionen gegen Nutzer die unerlaubte Inhalte online stellen zum B&B dass die irgendwie,
gewarnt werden nicht mehr so viel Terror posten,
oder dass Ihr Konto halt vorübergehend oder dauerhaft gesperrt wird ja.
Ja da.
Da habe ich sogar ein gewisses Verständnis dafür weil bei bei manchen dieser upload-filter ist es so wenn du da wirklich versucht jetzt.
Übungsvideo oder Kinderpornografie hochzuladen wird der Upload verhindert.
Es gibt aber keine Meldung an eine Strafverfolgungsbehörde und im Grunde ist dieser versuchte Veröffentlichung von dem illegalen Inhalt ja auch schon der versuchte Straftat also da gibt es sogar,
das würde Sinn machen dass die Plattform wirklich auch meldet und dass die realen Probleme,
auch dann wirklich behandelt werden aber natürlich auch wiederum nur im mit Maßgabe des Rechtsstaats und so weiter aber ich will noch gerne auf den anderen Punkt kommen nämlich.
Das was die Kommission oder was sie hoffe ihr auch fordert dass die,
großen Plattformen den kleinen helfen können sprich wir bauen alle den Content Filter von YouTube ein von Google.
Daher kommt auch das ganze Datenschutzproblem weil.
Nachdem diese Argumente von wegen das führt zu overblocking gehört wurden in den Verhandlungen gibt es jetzt eigentlich nur noch Texte die auch so einen Möglichkeit einer Beschwerdestelle vorsingen.
Wenn overblocking passiert das bedeutet aber auch du musst dem Filter sozusagen personenbezogen melden welche Upload jetzt hier gerade passiert,
neben der Tatsache dass ein Heimweh du natürlich auch Gesichter hatten ansich personenbezogen ist hast du damit sozusagen noch mal viel mehr einen anderen Datenschutz Kollateralschaden endlich die gesamte kulturelle Produktion dieses Kontinents zu Verabredung zugeschickt.
Also nur um das klar zu machen.
Super dann haben wir die den thematischen Rahmen für die nächsten Wochen gesteckt sie werden also weiterhin schlechte schlechte Nachrichten und schlechte Themen haben aber mit,
eurer Hilfe werden wir wenigstens keine upload-filter und kein.
Leistungsschutzrecht auf EU-Ebene haben und das ist doch toll dass ihr jetzt ich dagegen einsetzt währenddessen.
Engagieren sich die NGOs in diesem Fall unsere Freunde in Frankreich und unsere Freundinnen und Freunde in Österreich neu,
und la quadrature du net,
haben wir haben bei einem p-256 schon kurz angesprochen als Jan Philipp Albrecht ja bei uns zu Gast war.
Die haben ihre Arbeit aufgenommen die dsgvo ist in Kraft getreten und Max stand morgens pünktlich um 7 Uhr mit einer neuen Klageschrift.
Parat und hat sich beschwert bei Facebook Instagram WhatsApp und Android Google Android weil die weil mein diese Dienste nicht,
nutzen kann ohne bestimmten Daten Nutzungen zuzustimmen.
Ja wir kennen das so sorry verdiene unterbrechen.
Wenn er sagt das erklärt erklär's mal also was das genau bedeutet.
Also wir kennen dass ihr alle wir wird irgendwie so vor Inkrafttreten der datenschutzgrundverordnung auf Facebook gegangen sind oder wegen welche Dienste,
hat das man zustimmen muss und einfach so ich kann hier jetzt nicht weiterklicken bevor ich nicht diesen Datenschutzbestimmungen zustimmen das Schlagwort dafür ist forced consent also wir werden gezwungen dazu dass wir diesen Datenschutzbestimmungen,
zu stemmen und das ist eigentlich nicht konform nach der neuen datenschutzgrundverordnung weil eine informierte Zustimmung,
muss freigegeben werden und verpflichtend kann nur die absolut notwendige Verarbeitung der Daten sein um mit diesem Dienst anzubieten aber eben nicht das ganze Profiling und was sonst noch so hier bei den mit den Daten gemacht wird.
Das finde ich irgendwie ganz kurz das finde ich sehr schön dass das also das.
Funktioniert jetzt auch und das also bei einigen die sich halt Mühe gegeben haben.
Hooters und ich finde das auch tatsächlich sehr schön also ich habe hier so eine gestern mit einer App da hantiert die,
bei meiner also einjähriger Ewald eine App hatte verschiedene Funktionalitäten und die waren jetzt datenschutzrechtlich relevant.
Ja und da waren vier Häkchen zu vier Funktionen dieser App,
AWO gesagt wurde wenn du hier was was ich Location Services haben willst dann musst du dir dessen gewahr sein dass deine Location auch an uns gesendet wird und wir machen damit folgendes und dann musst du zustimmen dann hast du diese Funktion.
Wenn du das nicht haben willst dann fehlt dir eben diese Funktion aber der Rest der App funktioniert und das gabs,
quasi aufgedröselt für vier Funktionalitäten die diese App hatte hat natürlich zur Folge gehabt dass ich am Ende alle vier Häkchen gesetzt habe ja,
weil ich diese vier Funktionen haben wollte aber es war das war der entscheidende Unterschied zwischen informed consent dass ich nämlich jetzt weiß auch krass so,
die Betreiber dieser App wissen wenn ich die Lauren cheval Pipapo Location Daten und so und das ist genau der Unterschied früher atm war es dann halt so du machst die app auf und dann steht da irgendwie hier einmal bitte akzeptieren und weiter,
und das machst du natürlich ne dafür ich denke das ist wirklich eine der sehr wichtigen und sinnvollen Errungenschaften der dsgvo.
Das war auch die Zielsetzung von Anfang an also Dieter Prinzipien privacy by design,
by default ziemlich durch dieses Gesetz das heißt die die Datenverarbeitung die App musst du datenschutzfreundlich wie möglich gebaut sein,
dann also die Voreinstellungen meldet sich an alles ist so datenschutzfreundliche möglich und du kannst selber entscheiden welcher Verarbeitung du zustimmst welche Daten du noch von dir her gibst an es muss halt wirklich in der Kontrolle des des des Nutzers sein,
Armon das ist Eigenbau Datenschutz sicher nicht Brüste verbietet uns nicht dass wir Dinge über uns teilen er verlangt nur dass wir vorher gefragt werden und unsere Zustimmung g.
Aber kommen wir zurück zu dem Fall von max.
Wir haben dem darüber geredet wird in unserem Büro und er hat das auch schon sehr schön angelegt weil er hat nämlich gegen gegen Facebook Instagram WhatsApp und Android diese Beschwerde eingereicht an das ist mehr oder weniger.
Derselbe Text es geht im Moment fast consent an der hat das in Frankreich in Belgien in Hamburg und in Österreich eingereicht und das da ist also halt Text auf deutsch englisch und französisch.
Belgien hat ja auch deutsches Absprache aber die ist noch Englisch und das schöne ist ja all diese Unternehmen sitzen in Irland.
Normalerweise müsste er wieder nach Irland gehen und sich mit denen streiten.
Anti irische Datenschutzbehörde ist ja weltbekannt dafür dass sie die besten Leute der Welt anstellt die die besten sind nichts zu tun.
Die sind dickliche Profis da drin zu vermeiden dass irgendwelche Entscheidungen treffen müssen jetzt ist es aber so dass alle diese.
Ein Datenschutzbehörden auch zuständig sind ich muss nicht mehr nach Irland ich kann in Österreich mich beschweren und die Österreicher machen damit die Nieren gemeinsam die Entscheidung,
und in dir mal jetzt in diesen vier Ländern eingereicht hat.
Die alle eigentlich sehr datenschutzfreundlich sind hat er schon meine vierzueins Premium gebildet gegen die irische Datenschutzbehörde weil die anderen Behörden die alle,
doch vielleicht das Gesetz Ernst Leitern,
haben jetzt gleich berechtigt auch Mitspracherecht und das wird dann natürlich auch innerhalb der Behörden jetzt sehr spannende Entscheidungsfindung werden und ist doch sicherlich so ein Testcase mal wie diese neue Kooperation zwischen den Datenschutzbehörden auf EU-Ebene so funktionieren wird,
anfasst consentis hat einfach auch eigentlich ist das Gesetz hier klar die Unternehmen probier mal ob sie.
Da auch dumme rumkommen und es ist genau richtig dass man hier mal dagegen schießt.
Was glaubst du ich wir hatten da ja paar Wochen oder Monate vorher schon auch mit Maxtor gequatscht privat kann mir jetzt ist ja klar dass er verrät man jetzt nicht zuviel das dass der das geplant hat.
Er war ja schon so ein bisschen überrascht dass dir das nicht.
Umgesetzt haben weil so schwer Verdi Änderung jetzt gerade bei Android nicht gewesen zu sagen na ja ok dann machen wir halt informed consent.
Also warum waren die vergibt eine Hypothese warum die so doof waren.
Gute Frage also.
Ich glaube man versucht einfach in in der Kalkulation jetzt sich vorab an das Gesetz zu halten und uns sein Geschäftsmodell vielleicht umstellen zu müssen weniger revenir zu generieren in indem man die Grundrechte der Leute mehr achtet,
Bad vielleicht einfach zu teuer und jetzt einfach mal zu schauen.
Kommen wir damit weg kriegen wir kriegen wir das auch noch so durch wie hoch sind dann wirklich die Kosten weil,
die maximal Strafen der datenschutz-grundverordnung werden wahrscheinlich nicht,
Zimmer voll ausgeschöpft werden sondern er irgendwo drunter liegen also ich glaube es ist ein Rechen Ding am Ende weil rechtlich ist das was jetzt hier getan haben schon ganz klar im roten Bereich das sollte es eigentlich nicht spielen.
Aber ich glaube halt einfach dass sie.
Halt schauen wie viel es kosten und und können wir es uns trotzdem leisten deswegen ist es ganz wichtig dass wird auch immer mehr Verbandsklagen eingebracht werden und auf Schadensersatz geklagt wird.
Das ist ja auch noch was schönes es wird haben wir können den emotionalen Schaden tut von Datenschutzverletzungen auch eben einklagen und das gibt noch mal ganz neue Möglichkeiten da auch mit einer Gruppe von Betroffenen agieren zu können.
Der emotionales.
Gibt's sogar sein kann kann wirklich ganz spannend sein auch haben wie hoch das dann wird also die die nächsten Urteile dir zweimal kommen muss man sich genauer anschauen.
La quadrature du net unsere Franzosen haben auch schon damit begonnen Unterstützer für Kollektiv Beschwerden zu sammeln da gibt's auch um die Durchsetzung der datenschutzgrundverordnung,
und sind schon rund 10.000 Unterstützer wo beschwere zusammengekommen und wir werden das auch noch mal verlinken wer am Kongress war wird sich den wir diese bekamen Campana schon bekannt sein,
am
So Facebook entscheidet er was ich lese und irgendwie ganz ganz nett aufgezogen und ist auf jeden Fall auch etwas wo man sich beteiligen kann vor allem eben wenn man Französisch spricht.
Dann großes Thema war ja das jetzt iwie lange Zeit hat die uns begleitet hat ja die die dsgvo oder wird ohne Ende zu Abmahnungen kommen.
Na das wird ganz ganz fürchterlich alle werden abgemahnt werden von ihren Mitbewerbern und so weiter.
Das ganz große also zusammengefasst ist ja so die Position die auch Max dazu hatte er die DMAX die Jan Philipp Albrecht dazu hatte sat also das Problem sind nicht.
Die dsgvo sein das Problem ist überhaupt dass man quasi kostennoten bewährte Abmahnungen in Deutschland so durch die Welt schicken kann und gerade Vorgespräch hast du gesagt in Österreich geht das gar nicht mehr sein deutsche.
Ich habe schon ja also zumindest die die erste Abmahnungen Österreich kostet noch nichts,
das heißt du kannst dich eigentlich du kannst die Sache klären ohne dass es was kostet ohne dass du irgendwie ein Anwalt involvieren musst also sollte das ja eigentlich sein ja also jetzt ein Rechtsverstoß der gerichtlich nicht festgestellt ist schon mit einer Strafe zu belegen,
hatte ich für ein bisschen extrem.
Ja
Auf jeden Fall gab es dann hier die Meldung die abmachen Maschinerie ist angelaufen und da muss man aber jetzt irgendwie sagen so,
ich sehe da jetzt alles ist relativ wenig es gibt wenige Fälle so von denen berichtet wird wohl daneben einen Mitbewerber den anderen jetzt irgendwie an abgemahnt hat weil der keine,
datenschutzvereinbarung auf seiner Webseite hat wird man halt sehen ob und was daraus wird sehr schön finde ich es gibt hier so eine,
öffne Webseite eines Tischlers wenn du da drauf kommst kommt halt so ein Hinweis also ein,
Fenster sehr geehrte Mitbewerber täglich bekommen wir Anrufe und Nachrichten Nachrichten über Abmahnungen die sie angeblich durch uns erhalten haben,
wir haben dies nie in Auftrag gegeben die Kanzlei ist auch nicht im Besitz einer Vollmacht und wir haben auch noch nie mit ihr gearbeitet.
Weiter ist alleine schon der angebliche Wettbewerbsvorteil völlig haltlos wir bitten Sie daher um Nachsicht,
um Verständnis für unsere Situation als Unternehmen sie haben von uns nichts zu befürchten bei Fragen stehen wir Ihnen gerne zur Verfügung das heißt die die Abmahnkanzleien am offenbar.
Mahnen ab ohne tatsächlich einen ein Mandat einer geschädigt.
Haben diese Abmahnanwälte abmahnen.
Das ist für dich dass ich denke schon dass man da jetzt ne also das wär jetzt,
tatsächlich mal etwas wo ich sagen würde das ist ein Fall für eine Abmahnung bzw in diesem Fall wärst du auch schon im strafrechtlichen Bereich irgendwie also das ist jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie,
BGB sondern dass es würde ich immer wenn er irgendwie eine Kanzlei gegen deinen Willen und ohne Vollmacht von dir anfängt dir zu schaden denke ich dass es eher was für eine,
öffne einstweilige Verfügung oder aber naja man sieht.
Dass die sich Anwälte in Ennenda sortes müsste er auch irgendwie mit dem Standesrecht nicht mehr vereinbar sein also ja ich meine geistigen Geschäftsmodell dahinter aber das schenkt euch wenigstens na ja.
Schämt euch genau schämt euch wenigstens und dann können das von mir aus machen aber ihr müsst euch schämen.
Aber das ist doch mal ganz schön dass es dass das da also der sind das große Drama offenbar ausgeblieben ist oder bisher noch nicht eingetreten ist ne mal mal mal schauen aber die sind diese Abmahner rei.
Das scheint tatsächlich das einzutreten was Jan-Philipp auch sagte man braucht für die Abmahnung jemanden der sich.
Quasi bestätigen benachteiligt sieht nur dann kannst du diese Abmahnung irgendwie.
Stattfinden lassen und im Moment scheint sich das offenbar eben auf die wenigen Fälle von irgendwelchen kleinen Konkurrenten zu beschränken die ja wo dann halt eher eine Sache aber weiß trotzdem wie sie jetzt haben.
Ein aus der hat der hat mich letzte letztes Mal abgemahnt weil ich ohne Baugenehmigung den den.
Die Hütte in Meter zu nah an der Grundstücksgrenze hatte und jetzt mal nicht,
die Tischlerei von dem ab oder so nah und nicht so wie es eben im Urheberrecht mit den Massenabmahnungen passiert dass es da im Prinzip einen Freibrief gibt von.
Den Rechte verwaltenden Konzernen die eben.
Diese Serienbrief Kanzleien damit beauftragt haben einfach pauschal Fett Geld einzutreiben das wird eben eben Bier bei der dsgvo in der Form.
Nicht so einfach möglich weil du eben jemanden brauchst der der glaubhaft machen kann das.
Seine oder ihre Rechte hier verletzt sind und dass es ihm die Grundbedingung begründen Grundlage als für eine Abmahnung.
Dann neue.
Trotzdem sehr schön trotzdem sehr schön dass die CDU jetzt auf einmal nett ivanja dann 2 echt schön so CDU,
parlamentaria gegen Abmahnungen neue Fraktion neuer Splittergruppe im Bundestag fand ich super na der Wirtschaftsrat Wirtschaftsrat der CDU der dann sagst du etwas gegen diese ab.
Oh ja bitte tut was tut etwas dagegen verhindert es lasst euch nehmt nehmen die Energie und,
schafft gutes in der Welt werdet diese abmahn das Abmahnung Wesen los aber nicht nur im datenschutzbereich sondern direkt überall und ihr habt etwas Gutes getan und kriegt eine lobende Erwähnung was der CDU Wirtschaftsrat bei Logbuch Netzpolitik,
relativ selten bekommen.
Da muss doch eigentlich rechtlich machbar sein rechtlich hat sich auch was getan mit einem LGH Urteil in Sachen Tag,
das hat auch Wellen geschlagen der Europäische Gerichtshof hat nämlich in einer Sache entschieden wo es um Facebook Fanpages bzw Facebook-Seite,
Wittwer Facebook Sonderseite betreibt wir haben sowieso glaube ich eine Verlobung Netzpolitik der wird den wird vielleicht schon mal aufgefallen sein.
Ja
Statistiken gibt die einem Facebook anzeigt darüber wie viele Nutzer jetzt gerade auf der Webseite waren der letzten Zeit und vielleicht auch noch vorher die kommen also die klassischen User Statistiken die man so kennt,
die werden einem von Facebook zur Verfügung gestellt ohne dass man sich dagegen wehren kann.
Diese Statistiken sind anonymisiert also man sieht nur wie viel Leute gerade kamen aber nicht wer genau unter das Problem ist aber dass diese Statistik,
natürlich personenbezogen erhoben werden mit Cookies und mit anderen Tracking Technologien die Facebook natürlich maximal einsetzt und da hat der ARGE hadern entschieden,
dass die Betreiber so einer Facebook-Seite auch mit verantwortlich im Sinne des Datenschutzes sind für diese Erhebung was.
Kurze Frage zu diesem Statistiken meinst du damit das unter dem Post steht so und so viele Leute haben den jetzt gesehen werfe hier Geld ein damit ihn mehr sehen oder ist es.
Dann noch eine eigene Seite wo du dir diese Statistiken anschauen kannst aber ja genau also das wird dir dann auch bei dem POS angezeigt als Betreiber und Facebook knatscht ich so ein bisschen da Geld einzuwerfen damit es mehr Leute sehen aber.
Er hat dich ein bisschen.
Genau darum dieser dieser Datenerhebung und Verarbeitung geht's eben in diesem Urteil und.
Natürlich nicht unkritisch weil als Facebook Seitenbetreiber hast du natürlich keinerlei Einfluss drauf was Facebook dir da anbietet und,
trotzdem kommst du jetzt aber nach diesem Urteil auch in mit in die Verantwortung man muss dazu sagen dieses AGH Urteil ist natürlich noch auf Basis des,
alten Datenschutzrechtes also der 19.95 EU-Datenschutzrichtlinie,
wird jetzt aber nach dieser OGH vorab Entscheidung von dem nationalen Höchstgericht das ist dorthin geschickt hat auf Basis der GP ausgelegt,
da kommt dann sozusagen schon doch die datenschutz-grundverordnung hat,
das Konzept von geteilten Daten verarbeiten also die Verantwortung wenn die bei mir als einer Partei liegt dass das geht auch nach der Grundverordnung insofern bleibt spannend wäre es ist kein.
Was kann ich denn die.
Also es ist eigentlich.
So eine Frage die jetzt der kriegt ja teilweise wirklich so die großen Brocken hingeschmissen wo man sich gepflegt drüber streiten kann ist das jetzt so oder so und dann trifft er halt mal eine Entscheidung genau auf die Frage die im vorgelegt wurde,
ans hier hat das halt auch gemacht.
Am Inn in der Praxis ist natürlich ein großes Problem weil nur weil ich bei Facebook eine Seite betreibe.
Daraus direkt abzuleiten das alles was Facebook dann.
Hut mit den Nutzern die auf diese Seite kommen im Sinne des Datenschutzrechts ist natürlich ein harter Brocken also nicht alle Entscheidungen des RGH sind immer so hundertprozentig der Weisheit letzter Schluss,
gelten aber leider dran das letzte gekriegt auf diese Continenta insofern ja was das jetzt genau für die Betreiber heißt kann ich auch noch nicht sagen ich hoffe dass man das dann in der,
Praxis am bisschen besser Regen wird können als es jetzt hier sich antwortet.
Okay also muss ich keine Angst haben dass Max jetzt irgendwie.
Doch wobei wobei.
Herr Herr dafür dieser Logbuch Facebook-Seite herrje ja ich ich bin da ja.
Ja da haben sie schon Podcast darüber zerstritten über solche Facebook-Seiten ich meine.
Ja das ist ja bei uns zum Glück.
Nah dran also ich bin es ist das kann man sehr.
Kann man mal empfehlen das gab vor einiger Zeit hatte vor ein paar Wochen hatte der Tim oder die Freakshow hatte zu Gas den Sebastian jabbo ster.
Im politischen Bereich sich eben sehr viel mit dieser Facebook Corey und sowas auseinander,
und der eine etwas andere Herangehensweise hat halt somit jahir Reichweite erlangen und was in deinen politischen Ziele und so und so geht das und aber kannst du halt sagen du spielst nicht mit aber der spielt eben die Musik,
und ähnlich verhält sich das ja auch mit der lnp Facebook-Seite die wir da unterhalten damit ihr schön und das macht ihr auch immer brav,
unsere Inhalte dort weiter verbreiten können wo sie am meisten benötigt werden nicht bei Leuten die Facebook Account haben das glaube dass die das für diese Menschen unsere Inhalte durchaus interessant sein könnten.
Und aus diesem Grunde haben wir eben diese diese lnp Facebook-Seite.
Jan das ist halt ja.
Stolz mich auch nicht.
Das ist halt das alte Problem ich weiß es hat doch der Unterschied Team sagt er immer Podcast finden sich in der Nische wo holen,
und an wenn es mir darum geht wirklich so ein spezielles Publikum zu machen ich schiele nicht auf das was andere tun nur um Reichweite zu erlangen um um quantitative anschlussfähig zu sein sondern ich mache irgendwie was ich mache in dem Stil und unabhängig dem Fire auch ohne Werbung,
dann ist es ist es schon kann man sich den Luxus wahrscheinlich leisten es auch nicht zu tun.
Aber ich sage jetzt nur unsere Vereine wie Center Parcs wenn du irgendwie Menschen mobilisieren willst damit sie sich bei der Politik beteiligen da musst du dahin gehen wo die Leute sind.
Da musst du auch irgendwie auf den auf den Marktplatz gehen dir die eigentlich nicht gefällt wenn dort die Debatte stattfindet und wenn der.
Demokratie ernst meinen da müssen wir die Leute ernst nehmen und zwar möglichst breit möglichst breite Kollisionen est-rechner Bürger Rechtsthemen,
haben wir nicht wie weiß nicht Agrar Bauernlobby an sich schon irgendwie eine gewisse Größe und können uns den Luxus leisten selber zu entscheiden wo die Debatte passiert,
also deshalb finde ich schon irgendwie legitim da auch dabei zu sein gleichzeitig.
Warum wir ständig ansteigen und diese Unternehmen irgendwie mal an unsere Rechtsordnung wieder wieder sich halten zu lassen sie dazu zu zwingen am gleichzeitig aber auch ich verstehe wunderbar wieso leide auch einfach weg,
bleiben davon dass muss diese Option geben ja wirklich sinnvoll.
Wäre eigentlich in Social Media Protokoll Interoperabilität oder diese Dinge aber wir leben halt leider in der Welt wo wir sind und da steht man von solchen Problemen.
Solche Probleme haben wir entgehen können wir den übrigens wenn ihr schön brav immer unsere Inhalte weiter empfehlt und in den in die sozialen Medien trägt Takt,
das freut uns immer sehr und hilft dazu hilft dabei dass mehr Leute das Evangelium der lnp Einhorn Standarte.
Wirklich zugetragen bekommen.
Wir bleiben bei bei der Klage rein also inzwischen wird ja net flüssig ist ja wird ja wirklich nur noch an Gerichten geschrieben und entschieden.
Der DCX hat.
Sich gegen den BND wehren wollen vor dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht lange Geschichte also der Auslandsgeheimdienst BND.
Leitet ja am d-c-fix.
Daten aus und zwar und Glasfaser Daten also es gibt die Glasfasern sim.de CX der größte Internetknoten Betreiber Europas glaube ich.
Oder ist das sogar der größte der Welt.
Verdammt noch größer aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Okay also auf jeden Fall ein sehr sehr großer dort der größte Torte in der größte deutsche Internet Exchange auf jeden Fall ich glaube auch der größte europäische.
Jetzt angeht der BND hin und sag guck mal hier ihr habt daher einen Knotenpunkt z.b. in Frankfurt stehen und da sind sehr schöne Daten und die wollen wir gerne haben und jetzt nehmt ihr bitte an diese Glasfasern kommen jetzt ein Y-Stück dran so ungefähr und dann wird das wird das einmal gesplittet und dann können wir darauf zu,
zugreifen und ihr müsst das jetzt tun weil wir den weil wir das dürfen.
Und der DCX hat das eben auch jahrelang getan weil er es eben musste und sagt dann hat er die Etix gesagt okay wir wollen das.
Nicht mehr.
Der Hintergrund ist an sie haben sich natürlich auf den ob das Artikel 10 Gesetz bezogen und der gibt eben diesen 20% trick her die.
Also der dieser 20% trägt war quasi dieses dieser dieser Aspekt dass die dass der Eingriff in das Fernmeldegeheimnis,
eben nur 20% der Verkehre betreffen darf und der BND macht aber quasi Sohn so ein Trick und holt sich einmal.
Alles holt sich und holt sich gerade einfach zu viel.
Damit eben 20 % das ist was er braucht ja also die die rechnerische Bezugsgröße wird einfach so stark erhöht dass die 20% letztendlich die 100% sind die sie haben wollen.
Na ja jetzt hat er DCX.
Da seit längerer Zeit keine Lust zu quasi bei dieser Grundrechtsverletzung.
Zu Komplizenschaft gezwungen zu sein und dann hat der DC costs na ja okay dann.
Klagen wird oder eher schaffen wir eine Klage.
Dagegen das zu müssen und gehen vor das Bundesverwaltungsgericht damit und das Bundesverwaltungsgericht hat.
Entschieden gegen diese gegen diese Anordnung kannst du gar nicht klagen und damit haben die Klage abgewiesen und.
Thema erledigt denn die diese ganzen die quasi ob diese Anordnung in Ordnung sind oder nicht dafür gibt's sie G10 Kommission und das ist quasi nicht die Aufgabe des BND sich um sich darum zu kümmern.
Und damit hat sich das erledigt,
in dieser einen Frage so jetzt wird jetzt bleibt den den DTZ offen der Gang nach Karlsruhe das hat Klaus Landefeld auch schon angekündigt dass er das tut.
Ja und er dafür dass er das tun wird und oder eben zum Menschenrechtsgerichtshof nach Straßburg könnte auch noch gehen.
Ja aber EGMR dort Jahre also europäischer Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte was ist sicherlich besser in Karlsruhe zu sein.
Wobei Gerichte haben ja oft immer so gewisse Konkurrenz Verhältnisse zueinander und schon allein die Ankündigung man könnte zum Menschenrechtsgerichtshof gegen könnte schon dazu führen dass Karlsruhe besonders gut für die Grundrechte eintreten will.
Wieso macht der G6 das eigentlich ist das aus aus Courage und Haltung heraus oder ist eine auch wirtschaftliche Sachen dahinter.
Nee das ist das ist in dem Fall kann man glaube ich also bin ich jetzt mal so frei und sage der das die machen das aus Courage ja also gerade Klaus Landefeld ist jetzt ja nicht irgendwer und,
dem liegt es an diesem Thema.
Klaus ist ein guter.
Er war.
Ja auch im nsaua meine ich wenn ich mich nicht täusche mal geladen und der hatte eine relativ klare.
Haltung zu dem zudem sie da verpflichtet sind die betrachten das eben mit mit Argwohn.
Und das ist glaube ich hier nicht nur.
Also da gibt es eben eine politische und Grundrecht Komponente zu der sie,
zu der zumindest er auch relativ offen steht dasselbe sagt hier das halte ich für ein zu massiven Grundrechtseingriff und ich möchte nicht daran beteiligt sein,
so und das ist ja auch das was der was das was das Bundesverwaltungsgericht aufgreift und sagt das zu beurteilen steht dir überhaupt nicht zu.
Du hast dir eine Anordnung und gegen die kannst du erst mal nicht klagen ob der Grundrechtseingriff Zuzug Rassist oder nicht entscheiden andere.
Und das ist quasi die also so interpretiere ich hier die die einige die die die die Entscheidung des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts dass sie im Prinzip sagen so dass was du hier gewählt hast ist.
In diesem Wege nicht zulässig und wir werden jetzt also weitergehen.
Abend ganz kurz für die österreichischen zuhören Artikel 10 Artikel 10 Kommission und Problematik,
ich versuch es kurz zu erklären du korrigierst mich dann also Artikel 10 des deutschen Grundgesetzes doch irgendwie das Grundrecht auf Privatsphäre und da gibt's aber ein Zusatz dass das eingeschränkt werden kann und ob,
diese Einschränkung ok isst,
prüft dann eine Artikel 10 Kommission sozusagen das ist der der Beipackzettel aus Kleingedruckte sie haben ein Grundrecht auf Datenschutz Ausnahmetatbestand hier und da wirds dann problematisch und scheinbar eben,
beruft sich auch gerade der BND mit dem überwachungs Massen Überwachungstätigkeiten auf genau die Entscheidungen dieser Artikel ziehen Kommission stimmt das ungefähr.
Ja side der Artikel ist relativ einfacher sagt das Briefgeheimnis sowie das Post und Fernmeldegeheimnis sind unverletzlich.
Und dann kommt aber Beschränkung dürfen nur aufgrund eines Gesetzes angeordnet werden also.
Es muss ein Gesetz geben das regelt wo eine Beschränkung des des Brief oder.
Post oder Fernmeldegeheimnisses stattfindet dient die Beschränkung dem Schutze der freiheitlichen demokratischen Grundordnung,
oder des Bestandes oder der Sicherung des Bundes oder eines Landes so kann das Gesetz bestimmen dass sie den Betroffenen nicht mitgeteilt wird und dass an die Stelle des Rechtsweges die Nachprüfung,
durch von der Volksvertretung bestellte Organe und Hilfsorgane tritt das heißt auf deutsch wenn das im Rahmen.
Der netteste das Aufrechterhalten der freiheitlich-demokratischen Grundordnung mit anderen Worten durch Geheimdienste geschieht ja dann.
Kann man das ersten zehn Betroffenen nicht mitteilen und.
Und zweitens kann man auch sagen es gibt kein Rechtsweg dagegen sondern man kann quasi die die Überprüfung findet durch.
Von der Volksvertretung bestellte Organe oder Hilfsorgane Stadt und das ist hier diese G10 Kommission das ist Prinzip genau das was also interpretiere ich das hier als line Jurist genau das was da steht.
Das kann passieren man kann es auch den Leuten den Betroffenen eben nicht mitteilen und es gibt eben auch kein Rechtsweg sondern von dem von der Volksvertretung bestellte Organe die das prüfen mit anderen Worten,
G10 Kommission und genau diesen Rechtsweg hat hier haben hier weder die Betroffenen noch.
Der der DCX der sagt er das finden wir irgendwie doof und so scheint hier dass das Bundesverwaltungsgericht gehört hat.
Also scheint wirklich ein Fall für caso zu sein weil das sind so ganz grundsätzliche Fragen,
und hoffentlich kann man die auch mal hinter der Grundrechte klären wir haben wirklich nur klagen und Rechtsstreite in dieser Sendung,
gegen das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz das letzte g wurde auch geklagt was ist denn da passiert.
Ja das da kommt jetzt die die die FDP,
kommt jetzt mal langsam in Bewegung das deutete sich ja schon ab wir hatten ja auch gesagt dass der Jimmy Schulz da jetzt wieder im im Rennen ist und also im im Bundestags rennen,
und.
Jimmy Schulz und Manuel Höferlin haben jetzt einen Jura-Professor namens Hubertus Gersdorf beauftragt eine Klageschrift gegen das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz.
Gesetz anzustreben zu formulieren und sie verfolgen damit folgende.
Strategie sie werden jetzt sie wollen also ans Bundesverfassungsgericht damit weil sie davon ausgehen dass dieses netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz verfassungswidrig ist.
Da können sie aber natürlich nicht direkt hin das heißt sie haben jetzt vor dem Verwaltungsgericht Köln.
Geklagt und erwarten dass dort also eine fachliche Vorprüfung vorgenommen wird und dann.
Das Verwaltungsgericht Köln sagt na ja so wie das hier aussieht müsste dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht erscheinen entscheiden und dann soll also das.
Das Bundesverwaltungsgericht Köln das hoffentlich daneben Weiterreichen an das Bundesverfassungsgericht so planen Sie und Sie sie haben im Prinzip zwei Kern Argumente.
Also wie ich das hier verstehe erstens dass sie sagen mehr.
Hier wird ja hier werden ja Medien reguliert hier wird ja quasi den.
Den Medien gesagt wie sie zu handeln haben und das auf einmal vom Bund und das geht ja so gar nicht denn diese Regulierung von Medien ist eigentlich Ländersache.
Und deswegen sagen sie Prinzip dass das Gesetz sowieso schon mal gar nicht geht und dann natürlich.
Die Sorge des overblocking also der der Eingriff in Grundgesetz Artikel 5 wo ich hier gerade schon die grundgesetz-artikel offen habe können wir noch mal ganz kurz den Artikel 5 uns anschauen.
Jeder hat das Recht seine Meinung in Wort Schrift und Bild frei zu äußern und zu verbreiten und sich aus allgemein zugänglichen Quellen ungehindert zu unterrichten,
die Pressefreiheit und die Freiheit der Berichterstattung durch Rundfunk und Film werden gewährleistet eine Zensur findet nicht,
diese Rechte finden ihre Schranken in den Vorschriften der allgemeinen Gesetze den gesetzlichen Bestimmungen zum Schutze der Jugend und dem Recht der persönlichen Ehre,
Kunst und Wissenschaft Forschung und Lehre sind frei die Freiheit der Lehre entbindet nicht von der Treue zur Verfassung.
Und sie sie argumentieren also naja hier das ist ja relativ eindeutig eine Zensur die da stattfindet und eben dieses overblocking ist daneben eine Einschränkung,
der Meinungsfreiheit weil die Filter notwendigerweise ein Alpha und ein better Fehler haben aber ganz schön angeschwollen wegen sehr vielseitig automatisierte Filter,
also das ist hier das Problem und wir trauen uns schon gar nicht mehr uns vernünftig zu.
Und uns in diesem Internet zu äußern.
So gehen die beiden ersetzt dagegen vor das wird ein bisschen dauern aber es ist dann also jetzt schön dass es getan wird.
Bin ich sehr gut und bin ja wirklich gespannt wie dieses Verfahren ausgeht es wäre schön wenn man irgendwie das nächste gehe noch mal auf Grundrechte vor Gericht prüft bevor wir das dann in anderen Ländern auch wieder so machen.
Ja aber.
Was was eine schöne Überleitung ist ich bin doch irgendwie so ein kleines Österreich Update geben.
Kurze Ausgangssituationen a.Inn in Österreich ist ja jetzt eben seit Dezember eine schwarz-blaue Bundesregierungen an der Macht so spricht,
GTEV Bier und die FPÖ haben sich unter Kanzler kurz zusammengetan und,
ja hatten ja schon irgendwie habe ich eine folge Sendung gesprochen über die ganzen Datenschutzgesetze die den sie uns zu geballert haben in den ersten 100 Tagen irgendwie Hansi 26 Gesetze vorgestellt davon.
Wann 16 mit unmittelbaren Datenschutz Bezug wir haben da irgendwie insgesamt 750 Seiten,
Gesetzesänderungen zum Datenschutz in Österreich gehabt die sind ja schon alle durch da geht's ihr auch schon wieder so um die Europarechts Tauglichkeit und wir werden an der Stelle wahrscheinlich.
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren anstreben versuchen es muss die Kommission machen aber die Kommission ist an der Stelle glaube ich sogar bereit Österreich auf die Finger zu hauen weil es reicht ganz klar,
hier EU Regeln gebrochen hat und die datenschutz-grundverordnung z.b. indem sie nationale Strafbestimmungen machen einfach klar Europa,
schwierig vorgegangen ist der hat schon die EU,
rechts Kommissarin gesagt dass das eigentlich so nicht geht und dann man prüft ob man Österreich da nicht irgendwie an die Kandare nehmen kann.
Ja aber dann geht's weiter das überwachungspaket was wäre ja über eineinhalb Jahre verhindern konnten ist jetzt endlich beschlossen worden und ist zum Teil auch schon in Kraft.
Haben jetzt hat 1. Juni sind zum Beispiel IMSI-Catcher und ich glaube auch die neuen Bestimmungen zur Videoüberwachung schon in Kraft,
der Bundestrojaner lässt noch auf sich warten der wird erst mit ich glaube 2001 120020 egal aber natürlich jetzt schon heftigste programmiert oder.
Eben.
Von Gamma eingekauft oder anderen Firmen da wird es vielleicht Verfassungsklagen geben da gibt es einige Oppositionsparteien die Interesse daran hätten zumindest diese Gesetze noch mal.
Österreich Pflicht gerichtlich prüfen zu lassen ja und das hat auch irgendwie zur Sendung Didi das große Thema was jetzt gerade so kommt ist so dieser Medienbereich.
AMS wann diese Woche in Wien eine Medien Enquete statt einer Kate ist eine parlamentarische Veranstaltung und wo über zwei Tage hinweg mit hauptsächlich expert.
Kühl und Expertinnen der Industrie gesprochen wurde ganz stark Privatsender vertreten waren und auch große Verlagshäuser und am schönsten,
dachte es eigentlich die Rede von Mathias Döpfner dem Vorstandschef von Axel Springer auf dem Punkt der der österreichischen Bundesregierung ins Gewissen gesprochen hat,
jetzt mit dem Beginn hatten Ratsvorsitz Österreich ist ja chefität der des Europäischen Rates für die zweite Jahreshälfte also,
auf jeden Fall dieses Urheberrechts Paket zu beschließen und wir brauchen Leistungsschutzrecht auf EU-Ebene zum Erhalt der freien Medien unter Demokratie in Europa.
Erbarmt auch ganz klar davor die e-privacy-verordnung zu verabschieden Gesetz was noch auf EU-Ebene gerade gemacht wird und so.
Das Briefgeheimnis absichern soll und auch ein ganz wichtiges Gesetz wenn es um online tracking und Überwachung,
und da will er hat auch das sind zwei Gesetze die jetzt unter der österreichischen Ratspräsidentschaft noch fertig verhandelt werden gemeinsam mit i evidence und und anderen Gesetzen die auch noch nicht politisch wichtig sind dass es steht ziemlich viel an.
Was jetzt die zweite Jahreshälfte alles in den Schoß dieser österreichischen Regierung fallen wird,
haben und genau das Mädchen Thema es hat einen an ganz Großes also es gibt.
Karin Österreich eine massiver Debatte dazu ob der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk in dieser Form weiter bestehen bleibt oder nicht.
Ey jetzt sag nicht bei euch steht da jetzt demnächst auch irgendwie so ein öffentlicher Rundfunk brexit an.
Es ist noch nicht so wie die no Billag Abstimmung in der Schweiz oder dass man grundsätzlich den öffentlich-rechtlichen,
an sich in Frage stellt und unter Gebühren abschaffen will und dadurch eigentlich die Existenzgrundlage vernichten will aber es ist definitiv ein Angriff auf den ORF der wird auf verschiedenen Ebenen geführt also ganz normal die FPÖ,
Ideen ORF oft als Lügenpresse bezeichnet wir kennen diesen Begriff der hat Geschichte,
Arm und und hat ihm auch generell irgendwie gab sie, immer schlecht weg bei diesem Medien und hingegen bei dem ihr boulevardesk rn Gratiszeitungen kommen sie gut weg,
das ist doch die eine Schiene und dann geht aber auch darum dass DAF ansich ist kritisches Medium natürlich Anna doch populistischen rechtspopulistischen Regierung,
Dorn im Auge ist und er ist es halt irgendwie so das Qualitäts Medium des Landes was die meisten Leute erreicht.
Das ist die eine Interessen slager II interessens Lage sind die privaten Medien.
Die natürlich durch den ORF Konkurrenz sehen auch das hat Geschichte wir erinnern uns vielleicht noch an die futurezone.
Das war in Österreich über lange Jahre eigentlich.
Nee das Vorreiter Medium für netzpolitische Berichterstattung ich habe schon mal gesagt noch netzpolitik.org.
Wie ist irgendwie so hat er definitiv futurezone in vor Augen gehabt wie sie sich,
gegründet haben und dass dieses tolle Format ist eingestellt worden.
Mit dem letzten ORF-Gesetz also wo ist einer der erfolgreichsten Online-Publikationen aus Österreich warm wurde sumup Gerät bzw verkauft an den kurierverlag und ist jetzt eigentlich was Games lich anderes mit Ausnahme von den zwei einzigen Kunden nicht Polizisten die es dort noch gibt,
aber,
egal was ganz wichtig ist halt dass es hier Interessen gibt auch von privater Seite und da wären dann halt eben so Dinger ins Feld geführt wie,
am Grunde Film Anteil des Kuchens Tyler Gebührengelder haben,
Arm und ist seinerseits argumentiert man dann halt so ja wieso machen wir nicht einfach in der Ausschreibung mit diesem Gebühren Topf der da eingesammelt wird und da die privaten können sich genauso drauf bewerben.
Und keinen Halt zu sagen auch Teile des Bildungsauftrags des ORF über übernehmen und kriegen dann auch die Gelder dafür oder eben DAF muss seine Archive öffnen,
anta das was du ORF produziert,
können auch die Privatsender nutzen die zweite Idee finde ich sogar irgendwie gut oder charmant wenn man einfach sagt dass es öffentlich rechtlich finanziert dann muss es,
aber nicht mit die privaten sondern allen frei zur Verfügung stehen wäre irgendwie toll wenn wir so einen creativecommons Medienarchiv hätten was es irgendwie nicht nach 7 Tagen die probiert wird sondern wo mal wirklich alles was mit Steuergerät,
bezahlt wir doch wirklich dann frei zur Verfügung steht aber wie.
Sag nicht ihr habt ihr diese depri bewertet.de Publikationspflicht auch.
Ja ja wir haben das leider von den deutschen abgeschaut ist es auch 7 Tage mit Ausnahme für zeitgeschichtlich relevante Dokumente er aber es wird auch mutwillig Kultur zerstört.
Hirschmann.
Es gäbe so viel zu reformieren irgendwie in den öffentlich-rechtlichen Sektor da da da ist es sicher sinnvoll eine Debatte zu führen auch darüber wie man irgendwie denn denn diesen diesen Bildungsauftrag im 21 Jahrhundert a ausführen will,
und da gibt es ja wunderbare Theorien von von Leonardo bis zT,
Idee dahinter wer eigentlich dass du sagst wir haben sowas Wikipedia die sind wunderbar gut darin langfristiges wissen aufzubereiten so wirklich die großen Themen aufs arbeiten aber sind wahnsinnig schlecht in aktueller Berichterstattung.
Hinweis nicht schlecht bei multimedialen Dingen machen eigentlich nur Text wenn du den öffentlich-rechtlichen daneben stellst merkst du dass die sich perfekt ergänzen Vörden.
Insofern es gibt es wirklich ganz viele tolle Ideen wie man öffentlich rechtliche Medien als 21 Jahrhundert anpassen kann diese Medien Enquete in Österreich ist.
Insofern vielleicht noch ein bisschen deine Hoffnung könnte man meinen aber unter dieser Regierung.
Und wenn man sich die hier die der Veranstaltung anschaut dann ist leider nicht davon auszugehen dass die guten Dinge am Ende dabei raus schauen.
Vor allem wenn man jemanden wie den den Vorstandschef von Axel Springer das Sprechen lässt ist schon eher klar sieht vielleicht ihr ein bisschen was.
Gestein wird gestrichen er.
Und weil wir vorher auch über Facebook welches gesprochen haben und darüber dass der ORF schon mal irgendwie die futurezone als erfolgreichstes online outlet einstellen musste er im vorauseilenden Gehorsam.
Hat der ORF vor diesem Video cats neuester schon wieder guidance rausgebracht und dort irgendwie auch sozusagen alle Social-Media-Kanäle.
Eingestellt also ich glaube.
70 % werden direkt eingestellt und das heißt eben auch all diese Debatten plattforme die man gemacht hat auf Facebook auf Twitter gibt es nicht mehr.
Wie rum.
Das kann irgendwie gute Gründe geben wie soll man sich gegen Facebook welches entscheidet aber es sozusagen da jetzt schon im vorauseilenden Gehorsam alles was nicht klassischer Rundfunk ist.
Mal prinzipiell einzustellen.
Zuweiser Angst haben dass es ihnen da in den Kragen geht weil die sagen das entspricht nicht mehr euren Auftrag oder oder warum haben sie es getan.
Jap das ist vorauseilender Gehorsam und wie soll ich jetzt auch so auf dieses Thema hinführen wieso das neben dem klassischen medienpolitische noch was Date politisches hat.
Wenn man sich diese Enquete mal genauer anschaut.
Abend genau im Vorfeld der enquetes ist ein Buch herausgekommen change the game von Corinna Milborn einer Bekannten Moderatorin aus Österreich und Martin Breitenecker dem Chef von.
Abyssphere dem gelben österreichischen Ableger der Pro7 Sat1 Mediengruppe.
Und davon ganz viele dieser die sind jetzt auch diskutiert wurden schon mal aufgezeigt und mit einem Punkt den die davor anschließt sicherer crisis Medienrecht für Facebook.
Was ist von einer Haftung für Plattformen haben für die Inhalte die diese Nutzer dort posten und,
das ist ist eine Idee die hört man in in Österreich zumindest sehr sehr oft sozusagen wir müssen Facebook und das Medienrecht holen und sind die nicht auch eigentlich wie wir es zeitungsherausgeber verantwortlich für das Wasser sie da veröffentlichen an meine übersieht dabei halt einfach das,
Deezer.
Inhalte hat nicht von Facebook geschrieben werden sondern von den NutzerInnen dort und das ist eben eine Vorabprüfung Stichwort upload-filter bräuchte damit Facebook sich von so einer Haftung wieder befreien kann.
Weil jedes Posting.
Persönlich bewerben mit Menschen anschauen lassen wird nicht geben dass das ist so die große Debatte der plattformregulierung oder der intermedial Agility die sich so durchzieht ja wir hatten das mit dem Upload filtern.
Üben mit dem Juve rechtsgesetz wir hatten es mit Seehofers Forderung wir haben es jetzt hier in Österreich wo die Gefahr sehr groß ist dass es wirklich so ein Mediengesetz geben wird das europarechtswidrig sein wird.
Weil das müsste mal auf die ourewäller machen aber diese Regierung der traue ich zu dass sie.
Solche Dinge trotzdem durch drückt an das ganze Zeit wirklich so eine weltweite Debatte in den USA gab es auch wir wissen wie gespalten die USA gerade sind es gab eingesetztes ist mit Stimmen von Republikanern und Demokraten angenommen worden.
Was auch,
dieses Haus privater Privileg in den USA einschränkt 60 tut Birdie wurde es dort verankert ist ist jetzt aufgeweicht worden wegen human trafficking also wenn wenn wenn wenn wir verkaufen Menschen Menschen auf Craigslist und dieses Thema hat es geschafft,
auch in der gespaltenen amerikanischen politischen Stimmung bei der Parteien zusammenzubringen und beschlossen zu werden.
Und ist auch schon in Kraft in den USA also das ist so glaube ich einer der größten Netz politischen Debatten.
Die wir in unserer Zeit gerade führen ist auch mit Abstand das komplexeste Thema dagegen ist Netzneutralität Datenschutz und alles andere simpel aber es kommt von allen Seiten und es wird sich auf jeden Fall in diesem Thema bald was tun.
Kurz noch mal zu dem Begriff der Enquete du hast jetzt gesagt das war eine zweitägige Veranstaltung unsere Hörerinnen kennen das wahrscheinlich eher,
noch aus der Internet Enquete die in Deutschland ja eine mehrjährige Veranstaltung war zu der Constanze Kurz bei uns auch noch mal,
Fazit vor.
Einem Jahr gegeben hat die da als Vertreterin des Chaos Computer Club sagt so ist das bei euch jetzt nicht angelegt oder das klang jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen anders.
Nesaea cats in Österreich bei Montage und Ketzer haben dasselbe Ziel wie die Internet und Cat das ist man noch immer die Politik Märkte ist ein Thema jetzt groß genug und wir brauchen irgendwie,
Bühne eine schöne Überleitung um um um die Simulation einer Debatte stattfinden zu lassen damit wir danach die Vorschläge die wir schon haben.
Begründen keiner mit dieser Enquete sozusagen wir haben wir machen uns vorher aus was das Projekt ist dann laden wir dazwischen irgendwie Experten ein haben der eine Debatte und danach.
Bringen wir dass es Begründung für die Vorschläge die wir vorher schon hatten in Deutschland was wenigstens so dass man sich unabhängige,
Arten von diversen Gruppen eben auch Zivilgesellschaft sitc zusammen geholt hat und mit denen debattiert hat das hat,
die österreichische Regierung nicht gemacht man hat eben überhaupt keine Zivilgesellschaft eingeladen man hat das eben wirklich nur mit Leuten aus der Wirtschaft bestritten auch Leute im ORF also im Grunde Jugend ist,
geht die Schonzeit,
Nintendo Button drinnen sind wurden nicht eingeladen man hat ihnen dann ganz zuletzt irgendwie noch so ein paar Tage vor der Veranstaltung Einladungen geschickt,
ja es ist gibt keine Sitzplätze mehr aber natürlich freuen wir uns wenn Sie vorbeikommen und wie gesagt aus zivilgesellschaftlicher Seite noch großes der Wissenschaft war eigentlich niemand präsent.
Und deswegen.
Oasis ist dass er so eine Augenauswischerei und nicht wirklich ernst zu nehmen aber es gibt ein live und man kann sich das anschauen.
A&E aber schon die Einladungsliste lässt danach einen warst aber am Ende dabei rauskommen wird ja.
Ansbach.
Wurde denn wenigstens deutscher Polit Talkshow Tradition entsprechend noch ein Titel mit Frage gesetzt.
Schaue nicht nein also ich kann es nur als Blumes Medienangebot gab auch wirklich so eine parallel und Caterer die Zivilgesellschaft hat dann irgendwie eine Gegenveranstaltung gemacht die offene Medien okay also.
Sind halt Grabenkämpfe am.
Und genauso dieser ganzen diesen ganzen Hintergrund dürfen wir uns vor allem wenn Österreich jetzt ab 1. Juli die EU-Ratspräsidentschaft übernehmen wird und ich habe zwar schon gesagt da wird's viel auch im netzpolitischer Gesetze gehen.
Die neben dem brexit und die neuen Budgetverhandlungen für die EU werden dazu die größten Brocken sein um dies inhaltlich geht gleichzeitig hat Andrea Jelinek die Chefin der österreichischen Datenschutzbehörde.
Wird jetzt Chefin des europäischen datenschutzausschuss ist.
Also die europäische die europäische Zusammenschluss von allen Datenschutzbehörden und die kann sogar auch.
Verpflichtende Empfehlungen abgeben also sie können in Streitfragen zwischen Behörden sogar als Streitschlichter eintretende sind recht wichtiges Amt was da,
mit einer österreichischen Behörde besetzt wird.
Genau gleichzeitig es auch in die österreichische Telekom Regulierungsbehörde die RTR hat den Vorsitz von bere von den.
Regulierungsbehörde für Telekommunikation die für die Netzneutralität zuständig sind.
Amt das heißt man merkt irgendwie dieses keine skurrile Alpenland Österreich hat dieses Jahr sehr viel.
Netzpolitik zu tun und insofern haben wir als Verein sehr viel zu tun auf diesem Jahr und an uns gedacht irgendwie ist es.
Auch mal vielleicht wieder an der Zeit dran zu erinnern dass wir von Spenden Leben weil die Arbeit die wir tun können wir nur machen wenn wir unabhängig von allen sind.
Und deswegen haben wir aber so eine kleine Aktion diesen Sommer wär Fördermitglied bei uns wird bekommt ein T-Shirt.
Also wir haben gerade ganz coole T-Shirts im Angebot wenn partitions fail epicenter rockst und Verfahren mitgeht wird.
Mindestens über 100 € im Jahr kann da ein T-Shirt von uns bekommen und wir schicken die auch nach Deutschland.
Geschickt die sogar nach Deutschland EU weiter Versand EU oder oder EU-weit oder nur.
Ich würde ja auch in die USA ziehen wir müssen mit Porto reden aber wir arbeiten ja zur Hälfte auch eine EU Themen die da auch nicht anders also ja EU-weit wir freuen uns über Fördermitglieder aus ganz Europa vor allem Leute die ne Zentralität wichtig ist dann macht ja auch Sinn.
Dann haben wir auch da wieder gute Anlagemöglichkeiten für eure Spenden.
Wir nehmen auch mitkommen.
Ihr nimmt auch Bitcoin ja wenn sich da noch jemand von trennt die werden die Bitcoins werden doch gehobelt.
Ja aber es kommt noch hin und wieder vor dass du das einem so I buy Bitcoins darüber geworfen werden also in manchen Momenten ja gibt scheinbar genügend Millionäre in diesem Bereich.
Dann bin ich freue ich mich auf die.
Auf die Brücke die die die Euro die Österreich Wochen in Brüssel und hoffe dass ihr die Unterstützung.
Und die Freude und den Mut voller Arbeit kriegt Geld auch wirklich inzwischen werde ich ja nicht müde zu.
Zu erwähnen dass wir beide ja jetzt auf ein paar Jahre zurückblicken in denen sich viel getan hat auch um um dich herum und das was du da aufgebaut hast irgendwie mal,
mit diesem AK Vorrat Österreich angefangen hat und inzwischen mit epicenter da ne relativ große,
Nummer mit in ordentlichen Track-Record geworden ist wir werden langsam alt Thomas darauf will ich hinaus.
Ja irgendwas will ich auch in Ruhestand gehen noch macht Spaß.
Noch der Wind wenn wir dann die Welt gerettet haben dann gehen wir in den wohlverdienten Ruhestand.
Vorher leider nicht ich danke dir für deine Hilfe hier haben bei diesem Podcast es sei denn muss noch was loswerden.
Der ich danke fürs dabeisein und ja freue mich über die Kommentare und.
Danke euch auch wieder für die 255 Sendungen - die dann wo ich dabei war also es ist doch immer wieder schön sich nur zurückzulehnen und zuzuhören.
Dann danke ich mal an dieser Stelle dem Tim der ja auch dafür gesorgt hat dass wir diese,
255 57 Folgen inzwischen aufgezeichnet haben und da heute ich der Aufnahmeleiter war,
ist mir mal wieder aufgefallen dass das echt scheiße ist,
herzensgut ist oder also nein das ist nicht echt scheiße es ist nur man kann man muss trotz allem sehr viel beachten und man kann durch den wenn man sich da einfach mal zu weit bewegt und zu kurzes Kabel hat die Aufnahme und die Nachproduktion,
durchaus verkomplizieren wie ich heute getan habe also vielen Dank an tim,
der diesem Podcast hier immer am Laufen hält durch sein großartiges Studio die Metaebene.
Und gleichzeitig dann möchte ich auch noch mal die Gelegenheit nutzen den Ralf Stockmann zu danken für Ultraschall,
das Podcast Produktions Tool welches Team verwendet und welches ich jetzt hier auch verwendet habe wo ich wirklich begeistert bin,
was da geleistet wurde und wird um Podcasting für alle irgendwie möglich und erschwinglich zu machen das ist,
einfach wirklich großartig was da an Tools bereitgestellt wird und geschaffen wird und eine wahre Freude das zu nutzen.
Scheitert wirklich alles was da noch ist bis dann wirklich meine Dummheit.
Und da diese beiden Danksagung wollte ich mal loswerden und natürlich danke ich ansonsten noch dem days.
Dem Jan den Benjamin und dem Steffen die mir hier große Freude gemacht haben.
Und damit glaube ich können wir sagen sind wir am Ende der Sendung angelangt und verabschieden uns von euch.
Tschüss bis bald.
Ciao ciao.